what i want to do in this video is show
you a way of subtracting numbers
that is different than the regrouping
technique and this is closer to what i
actually do in my head and this might
not be what you see in school so be
careful while you're looking at this
some people might not fully approve of
what i'm about to show you but the idea
the reason why i'm showing you this is
to understand that there's not just one
way to do things as long as you
understand the underlying principles
what these numbers represent and you do
things that make sense you should be
okay and what's neat about this
technique is we don't have to regroup
we're just going to start with the
hundreds place and just keep on moving
so for example if i think of 301 i first
want to subtract 100. so 300 minus 100
is going to get me to 200
now i need to subtract 60 and so i can
think about what is 22 0 minus 6 so this
is essentially saying what is 200 minus
60 well 20 minus 6 is 14. so i just
subtract and now i'm left with 14. and
so now the problem has resulted in 141
minus 9. so i really just have to think
about what well or i could do what 141
minus 9 is well 141 it's a little bit
more mental computation than you might
be used to but 141 minus 9 is going to
be
132. so we are left with 130
100 132 let's do this one same technique
i encourage you to pause the video and
try it yourself the same technique
well nine minus two it's really 900
minus 200 you're going to be left with
700
then 71
minus
eight seven you see eleven minus eight
is thirteen so you're going to be left
with
you're going to be left with 63
and now we have to subtract 633
minus six 13 minus six is 7 so it's
going to be 627
627 and once again try to pause the
video do it on your own
so i don't have any hundreds to subtract
so i can immediately go to 72 minus 8
which is really 720 minus 80. but let's
just think in terms of 72 minus 8. well
12 minus 8 is 4 so 72 minus 8
is going to be
is going to be 64. so now this is the
same thing as 641 minus 8.
well 41 minus 8 is going to be
33. i have to do a little bit of mental
computation here so this will result in
633.